bonsoir l'avion explosera à 13 heures
précises demain dimanche si le
gouvernement allemand ne cède pas la
menace répétait encore aujourd'hui par
le chef du commando de terroristes qui a
détourné le boeing de la lufthansa
cette menace n'a pas varié d'un iota
aujourd'hui la guerre des nerfs entre
les terroristes et les autorités
allemandes à propos de la vie des otages
et à propos de la vie du patron des
patrons restent allemand a donc continué
aujourd'hui tout au long des heures à
dubaï l'aéroport où s'est immobilisé le
boeing de la lufthansa les négociations
se poursuivent par radio entre les
pirates de l'air et les autorités
locales
détail dérisoire mais qui a tout de même
son importance dans ce genre d'affaires
on a apporté aux passagers de l'avion un
énorme gâteau pour fêter l'anniversaire
d'une des hôtesses une façon de détendre
l'atmosphère
une façon aussi pour les deux hommes qui
sont venus porter le gâteau d'observer
ce qui se passe dans l'avion tout est
bon dans cette guerre psychologique dans
la porte du boeing de la lufthansa
immobilisé maintenant depuis plus de 36
heures sur l'aéroport de dubaï
l'homme qui serait le chef des cats
terroristes responsables du détournement
on peut voir une arme dans sa main
gauche le chef du commando le commandant
walter mohamed est toujours en contact
avec la tour de contrôle de dubaï
mais jusqu'à maintenant il a refusé de
libérer qui que ce soit et a réaffirmé
que si les revendications des
terroristes n'étaient pas satisfaites à
12h gmt demain l'avion avec ses 82
passagers et cinq membres d'équipage
sauterel l'appareil a été ravitaillé en
carburant afin de faire fonctionner la
climatisation semble t-il de même de la
nourriture et des boissons pour les
otages ont pu être livrés ainsi que des
médicaments
l'envoyé spécial du chancelier schmitt
le ministre vichnievsky est arrivé à
dubaï ce matin - pour tenter une
négociation directe sans doute que pour
tenter tenir le gouvernement de bonn au
courant de l'évolution de la situation
renseignez donc presque minute par
minute par son envoyé spécial le
chancelier schmidt se trouve devant la
plus écrasante responsabilité humaine
qui est connu un un dirigeant ouest
allemand depuis la fin de la guerre
que peut-il faire et que doit-il faire
face à ce dramatique défi que lui a
lancé une poignée de terroristes de
réunion de l'état major de crise en
conseil des ministres extraordinaire les
responsables allemands se consultent
sans arrêt depuis quelques heures
l'opinion publique s'interroge elle se
demande elle aussi s'il ne faut pas
céder
michel meyer vous êtes en direct avec
nous de bonne ouïe et derrière les
grilles et les fenêtres de sa
chancellerie
el mout mythe mènent une véritable
course contre la montre et peut-être
contre lui même
personne ne sait à 100% quelle a été sa
décision mais l'impression qu'il a peut
être céder aux injonctions des
terroristes se précise sans pouvoir être
confirmés
il répond en cela à la tente des
allemands et des grappes humaines qui
continuent de se regrouper devant le
siège de la chancellerie prend tout cet
homme il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
de libérer les membres de la bande à
baader
à mon avis on doit tout faire pour
sauver les otages nous dit également
cette date dans tous les cas la vie des
otages et de monsieur flyers doit être
préservé c'est primordial
on dit également cette autre femme qui
se trouve devant la chancellerie céder
serait cependant une humiliation très
grave pour l'état de bonnes les hommes
politiques en sont parfaitement
conscients et la gravité de la situation
se reflète sur les visages du citoyen
d'une allemagne fédérale
choquée et horrifiée par le défi
terroriste actuelle à l'eau paris oui
quel signe d'après vous peuvent laisser
penser que le gouvernement allemand
pourrait céder et bien tout d'abord le
fils de monsieur reims martine flyers a
tenté à la mi-journée de verser la
rançon exigée par les ravisseurs de son
père depuis l'enlèvement de ce dernier
il ya maintenant pratiquement plus d'un
mois il a tenté de verser une rançon de
15 millions de dollars
mais en dernière minute à la suite d'une
indiscrétion de presse cette rançon n'a
pas pu être versés dans l'hôtel de
francfort où cela aurait dû se faire
de source sûre je peux aussi vous dire
qu à toutes fins utiles la lufthansa
tient plusieurs appareils à en alerte en
réserve avec et qui part de la même
manière la télévision allemande se
prépare à installer des équipes de
direct dans les endroits névralgiques
important de cette série d'événements
c'est à dire devant la prison de
stuttgart allemagne où se trouve andreas
baader ainsi qu'à l'aéroport de ce trop
de francfort où pourraient
éventuellement être rassemblés les
terroristes qui doivent être libérés
avant leur envol pour une destination
encore inconnue
par ailleurs des contacts précis existe
déjà entre le gouvernement de bonn et le
gouvernement de somalie
la somalie devraient être éventuellement
le territoire sur lequel les terroristes
libérés devrait trouver asile
vous avez des éléments michel meyer qui
pourrait prouver au contraire que bones
ne cédera pas aux exigences
oui et bien aux dernières nouvelles un
avion de
la lufthansa avec à son bord un commando
spécialisée dans la lutte antiterroriste
s'est posé à dubaï dans le courant de la
journée
c'est dire que ce commando composé de
policiers d'élite
un peu comme notre brigade anti gang
pourrait éventuellement intervenir dans
le courant de la nuit
dans la mesure aussi où les autorités
locales de dubaï ont jusqu'à présent
refusé de faire le plein complet de
l'appareil
on peut penser qu'une telle opération
est actuellement envisageable en outre
c'est toujours le calme relatif dans les
prisons allemandes dans les prisons
ouest allemande on se trouve les
terroristes que le groupe qui a enlevé
monsieur flyers et les pirates de l'air
de dubaï demande de libérer ses
prisonniers n'ont pas encore été libérés
il semble que rien ne se passe à l'heure
actuelle à ce niveau là et si l'on veut
respecter l'ultimatum qui est fixé
demain matin à 9h il faudrait tout de
même que quelque chose se passe mais
cela peut se produire éventuellement
dans les prochaines heures
on dit aussi michel médias qu'ils ont
été mis au courant du développement des
négociations aide est de la faire de
left hand ça ça prouve ça prouve que
leurs contacts avec l'extérieur reste
possible malgré l' isolement complet
dans lequel il se trouve depuis
maintenant depuis l'enlèvement de reims
martin schleyer cela prouve que le
téléphone arabe si l'on peut dire
fonctionne entre les terroristes
emprisonnés et leurs complices très
actif qui se trouve à l'extérieur bien
merci michel meyer à propos aussi de la
faire ch la guerre il faut savoir que
dans l'après-midi m paillaugue l'avocat
suisse qui a servi d'intermédiaire avec
les halls des terroristes qui ont enlevé
le patron des patrons restent allemand m
paillot a reçu un message extrêmement
importants et urgents des autorités
allemandes à l'intention des terroristes
on ne connaît pas le contenu de ce
message pour l'instant elles sont
peut-être certaines indications sur la
présence de monsieur chevalier en france
et du commando qui le garde en otage la
gendarmerie a lancé une opération de
contrôles la nuit dernière sur le canal
de la marne à la saône
aucun résultat concret semble-t-il après
ces contrôles rendue difficile par le
brouillard et le nombre important des
péniches qui naviguent sur ce canal est
puissant rapport semble-t-il avec ces
événements bien que dans leur message
les deux japonais est évoquée à mots
couverts le détournement du bo
deux hommes se sont emparés d'un autobus
ce matin à nagasaki au japon
il garde en otage 12 passagers ils ont
relâché dans la journée un homme de 72
ans malade et de femmes il menace de
faire sauter l'autobus
si la police attaque ils n'ont pas
formulé des exigences précises pour
l'instant retour en france avec au
palais des congrès depuis ce matin le
début d'une opération organisée par le
patronat portes ouvertes sur
l'entreprise une opération qui précède
les quatrièmes assises du cnpf qui
auront lieu lundi et mardi à paris
s'adressant à trois ou quatre mille
cadres réunis au palais des congrès
monsieur françois ceyrac a expliqué
qu'il souhaitait un rôle nouveau pour
l'encadrement dans les entreprises elle
a proposé aussi la multiplication des
usines à la campagne nous reviendrons
sur ce sujet demain soir avec un
reportage d'hervé claude dès ce soir je
vous propose d'écouter la courte
déclaration faite par monsieur bart qui
inaugurait cette après midi cette
opération portes ouvertes
inaugurant les journées portes ouvertes
du cnpf monsieur bart a mis l'accent sur
la qualité du travail le travail at il
déclaré
ne doit pas être une activité servile
mais doit servir à l'accomplissement de
l'être humain
puis le premier ministre a parlé de
l'autogestion je vois que l'autogestion
et comme toutes les utopies la
traduction d'une sorte de 26 ans devant
les conditions actuelles dans lesquelles
on vit alors on imagine le monde idéal
auquel on souhaiterait participer mais
c'est un monde idéal nous savons bien
que il ya des contraintes de tous genres
et je crois que le propre de l'action
c'est en fonction de l'idéal de voir les
contraintes qui s'imposent mais
d'aménager les contraintes de telle
sorte que l'on puisse sans cesse se
rapprocher de l'idéal mais vous savez
que l'idéal on n'atteint jamais car si
on la tenait un jour il cesserait d'être
un idéal c'est le ressort c'est le
ressort de l'activité individuelle
cette opération porte ouverte qui sera
suivi par les assises nationales du
patronat permettent aux patrons de
s'interroger aussi sur leur avenir pour
le cnpf un nouveau type de patron semble
n'être jacques merlino est allé
rencontrer l'un de ces nouveaux managers
gens de cassagnac ouvert au dialogue
attentif aux désirs du personnel et leur
laissant la plus large liberté la plus
grande responsabilité
c'est le nouveau visage que le patronat
veut donner de lui même opération poudre
aux yeux pour les un opportunisme
électoral pour les autres il reste qu'il
est vrai que sur les quatorze mille
nouveaux patrons qui chaque année
créer une entreprise nombreux sont ceux
qui pour avoir été salariée garde un
mauvais souvenir du patron de droit
divin et souhaite inventer de nouveaux
rapports dans l'entreprise si j'avais
été car dans plusieurs grandes
entreprises ayant souffert si vous
voulez de ne pas pouvoir m'exprimer
librement et de pouvoir mener mais vu
jusqu'au bout j'ai décidé de créer une
entreprise avec extrêmement peu de
capitaux car mon propre capital était ma
voiture ainsi que quelques centaines de
milliers de francs siens j'avais et j'ai
tout investi dans une entreprise c'est
devenu patron parce que vous n'aimez pas
les patrons là ce pas exactement passé
dans les grandes entreprises dans
lesquels je travaillais je ne
connaissais pas les grands patrons avec
lesquels j'avais à travailler fois où
j'aurais dû avoir à travailler mais
disons l'encadrement m'a terriblement
gêné et me freinait dans ce que j'avais
envie de faire
alors j'ai décidé
dalé m'exprimer chez moi et j'ai créé
une petite entreprise dont l'autorité si
vous voulez je pense que c'est quelque
chose de naturel
on a ou on n'a pas l'autorité alors que
les gens puissent vous contestez ça n'a
pas d'importance et en aucun cas ça vous
retire votre autorité dans cette
entreprise
si des gens quelque chose à dire leur
devoir c'est de les dire si ça doit
contester mon autorité main tant pis ça
conteste mon autorité mais au moins
c'est naturel
le chef d'entreprise travail comme tout
le monde il fait un métier il a qu à
bien faire son métier ça suffit c'est
pas très compliqué à ordre est donné à
la comptabilité de fournir tous les
récents tous les renseignements qui
pourraient être demandés quelle que soit
la nature du renseignements demandés
aussi bien mon salaire ce n'est pas un
secret vous semblez assez loin du
patronat de droit divin un traditionnel
vous considérez comme un marginal du
patronat ou comme une avant-garde 3
honnêtement je ne sais pas où je me
situe dans le patronat je suis un patron
ce que je sais c'est que dans le
patronat classique beaucoup de gens à
l'heure actuelle s'excuse d'être patron
on essaye de dire je suis le grand frère
je suis le manager je suis je suis je
suis je suis n'importe quoi mais surtout
par le patron alors moi j'ai une petite
entreprise avec mes trois petites
entreprises en un peu près une
soixantaine de personnes
eh bien à bord je suis le chef
d'entreprise je suis le patron
et comme on disait dans la marine
j'assume d'achat sur les deux millions
de patrons français combien celui prêt à
se remettre ainsi en cause le micro
fermé notre interlocuteur nous confiait
quelques dizaines peut-être
sa force est chez
pas de portes ouvertes au contraire huis
clos pour la réunion à paris du conseil
national du parti républicain
les travaux ont commencé aujourd'hui ils
continueront demain
il s'agit de mettre au point le projet
républicain
jean-pierre 60 secrétaire général du
parti républicain vous êtes avec nous en
direct
je sais que vous êtes actuellement
d'ailleurs dans la salle de ce conseil
national et que vous avez interrompu vos
travaux pour nous je vous en remercie
vous dites projet républicain jean
pierre soisson le cds il ya quelques
jours disait plateforme est ce que vous
avez peur des mots pourquoi vous dites
pas programme électoral le projet
républicain et le programme du parti
républicain est en ce moment les
téléspectateurs peuvent voir le bureau
politique du parti républicain qui est
filmé en direct et qui est l'instance de
décision du parti et le conseil national
en ces deux journées va élaborer le
programme ce ne sera pas un catalogue de
mesures mais il déterminera nos axes
d'effort pour les prochaines années
si vous permettez monsieur besson
pourquoi parler maintenant d'un projet
du parti républicain est ce que le vrai
projet giscardien ce n'est pas le livre
du président de la république démocratie
française serait-il oublier bien
évidemment pour nous la kz2 tout ce que
nous faisons c'est le président de la
république et donc nos travaux se fonde
sur démocratie française et il n'ya là
dessus aucune ambiguïté profonde est
vrai vous dire qu'il ya eu dans la vie
politique au cours des dernières années
au fond deux courants essentiel il y a
eu le courant qui a conduit les partis
de l'opposition a signé un programme
commun en 1972 il a constitué une
illusion il vient de se dissiper il ya
l'autre courant beaucoup plus fort qui
est le nôtre qui ressurgit actuellement
et qui le courant qui a permis
l'élection en 1974 de valéry giscard
d'estaing
eh bien nous nous situons dans ce
courant là quand vous parlez de ce
courant et c'est une nouvelle majorité
que vous esquissez ou est ce la même
majorité élargie et notre objectif est
très simple c'est de donner l'année
prochaine au président de la république
une majorité parlementaire qui lui
permettent de poursuivre son oeuvre de
progrès ce n'est pas autre chose
une majorité pour le président vous avez
dit ce matin que vous ne vouliez pas
faire de triomphalisme
or le parti républicain se proclame
aujourd'hui le premier parti de la
majorité est le second parti de france
n'ont pas de cocorico pas de cocorico
nous avons
en quelques mois gagné énormément et
nous sommes passés de 16 à 21 % des
intentions de vote des français ce qui
est considérable mais pas de cocorico et
je ne dirai rien qui puisse compromettre
l'entente retrouver la majorité parce
que notre premier objectif a été de
faire l'entente de la majorité ayant
fait l'entente de la majorité notre
deuxième objectif
et d'affirmer le courant du président de
la république
le courant qui lui permette
véritablement d'avoir pour lui une
majorité dans le parlement de 1978 donc
aucune tentation au sein de la majorité
d'être sûr de vous et dominateur jamais
et si vous êtes aujourd'hui si vous
proclame higgs est aujourd'hui le
premier parti de la majorité je voulais
cette responsabilité nous n'avons rien
dit de de cela nous sommes un parti qui
a gagné des voix
nous sommes un parti essentiel est
essentielle à la victoire de la majorité
mais nous ne faisons aucune comparaison
avec les autres formations
monsieur bart s'est donné comme
étiquette soutien à l'action du
président de la république fait une très
bonne éthique est tous les candidats du
père auront-ils cette étiquette tous les
candidats du p r se donneront comme
objectif premier de soutenir l'action du
président de la république
et si nous nous entendons avec monsieur
bah sur une telle étiquette bien
évidemment tous les candidats du parti
l'adopteront qu'est ce qui va faire
l'unité de la majorité s'il ya des
programmes des plateformes et des
projets différents l'unité de la
majorité cette président de la
république et le manifeste devient nous
avons signé le manifeste qui a manifesté
l'entente retrouver la majorité
à partir de ce manifeste chaque parti
adopte son programme ensuite il ira ce
qui revient au gouvernement et au
gouvernement seule et monsieur bart
indiqué très nettement la télévision qui
proposerait au gouvernement français des
objectifs d'action nous soutiendrons des
objectifs d'action de monsieur bart je
vous remercie
quand journée d'explications aussi pour
le parti socialiste en france
aujourd'hui une journée de formation
réservée aux militants qui se sont
réunis avec les responsables nationaux
sur le thème de l'identité du parti
socialiste
le début en fait d'une grande campagne
d'explication qui se poursuivra dans les
semaines à venir par des séminaires des
stages régionaux et des meetings dans
les principales villes de france louis
doucet a suivi pour nous la journée de
formation de la fédération de la seine
saint denis à pavillons sous bois dans
la région parisienne la polémique
ouverte par le parti communiste n'est
pas nouvelle et vous souvenez touche
qu'au lendemain des élections partielles
de l'otan'' mine de quoi qu'il était
question cours deuxième journal
d'information du parti socialiste est
bien haut sans doute pas de problème sur
l'identité du poste ses buts de talent
l'autogestion la lutte contre la droite
est une évidence et d'union de la gauche
une nécessité mais pas n'importe quelle
union
il convient de rester fermes sans pour
autant alimenté la polémique en ouvrant
les placards pour se lancer de vieux
cadavre à la tête voilà
mais tout de même on a posé les
questions qu'elle il fallait s'attendre
sur les rapports avec et comme et
l'union de la gauche
si il ya des similitudes dans le refus
de participation du pc gouvernement de
front populaire de 36 et la façon dont
on s'oriente actuellement la position du
pc vis-à-vis d'une éventuelle victoire
de la gauche et de son retrait les
l'hypothèse des hypothèses éventuel
qu'on peut faire à ce sujet il est une
question que je me pose 10 pas me
rappelant déjà toutes ces erreurs
pourquoi fut pas très au courant de ces
questions là pourquoi à nouveau les
socialistes se sont ils dit avec états
unis moi je crois que c'est extrêmement
intéressant de voir comment
l'eurocommunisme répond positivement à
certains points locaux certains points
nationaux je pense que c'est pas du tout
en état de crise je crois que c'est
parler de crise et se placer dans la
logique stalinienne des années de la
guerre froide et ce qui peut être
inquiétant dans le communisme c'est
l'alliance entre une bourgeoisie
nationale et le mouvement communiste de
façon à éviter l'alliance direct entre
socialistes et communistes et en espagne
comme en italie comme en france
on peut se demander s'il n'ya pas
effectivement accord tacite ou explicite
pour éviter l'alliance socialiste
communiste et bien comme on peut le voir
que ce que journée d'information ne
semble être actuellement destinée à
resserrer les boulons
les poules ans je ne crois pas défaillir
serré dans sept nains sont partis vous
avez pu voir comité directeur il ya eu
unanimité d'appréciation nous sommes là
pour une campagne d'explication ce que
j'observe c'est que depuis que le parti
communiste a développé sa polémique
nos militants s'interrogent mais aucun
ne soupçonne sont partis d'avoir trahi
le programme commun voilà donc pour la
journée d'action du parti
explication du parti socialiste avant de
poursuivre dans l'analyse des événements
d'actualité aujourd'hui
retour à bonn où michel meyer je crois
vous venez d'apprendre d'eux des
informations nouvelles à propos du
détournement du boeing wii vient julia
tout simplement devoir rendre ce martin
schleyer le patron des patrons allemands
à la télévision allemande
la télévision allemande à accepter ou à
diffuser en quelque sorte la bande vidéo
la bande magnétoscope sur laquelle il
lancé un appel au gouvernement pour une
décision celle un phénomène sans
précédent précédent car cela signifie
que le black out qui régnait sur
l'information concernant cette affaire
depuis maintenant un mois élevé et c'est
là un signe fondamental pourquoi un
changement est en effet intervenu dans
l'attitude du gouvernement à cet égard
on ne prend en effet pas le risque de
des veillées éventuellement de la part
de la population allemande de la pitié
pour un homme que l'on veut sacrifier
effectivement l'image que donnait ce
soir un smart ont chuté hier la
télévision était effectivement pitoyable
c'est donc que le gouvernement allemand
a décidé de céder aux ravisseurs de
reims particulière la preuve c'est qu'il
les montre et tel qu'il était c'est à
dire assez misérable ce soir à la
télévision allemande est un homme que
l'on de sacrifier on ne montre pas dans
cet état et à michel meyer d'autre part
en france le gouvernement français est
ému de ce qui se passe à dubaï c'est
monsieur raymond barre qui l'a déclaré
ce soir au micro d'europe 1 je comprend
notamment la situation particulièrement
difficile faite au gouvernement allemand
j'exprime personnellement toute ma
sympathie à l'allemagne fédérale
je vous rappelle que nos émissions nous
avons des émissions du matin sur antenne
2 nous avons un programme diffusé à
partir de 9 heures demain matin s'il se
passe évidemment quelque chose
d'important nous pourrions intervenir à
quelques moments que ce soit sur antenne
2 le matin accident la nuit dernière sur
une plateforme de production de gaz
naturel dans la mer du nord un plongeur
français qui travaillaient sur une
soupape a été tué on ne connaît pas
encore les causes de cet accident
le gaz naturel s'échappe de la soupape
défectueuses mais il n'y a pas de risque
de pollution car ce gaz c'est l'apport
dans l'air et puis début ce matin à
marseille de l'opération janus 4 elle
est destinée à prouver que l'homme peut
travailler sous la mer à 500 mètres de
profondeur
six plongeurs participent à cette
expérience qui a commencé comme prévu ce
matin par les opérations de compression
on a perdu
le yacht français 33 export personne n'a
vu le bateau à la fin de la première
étape de la course autour du monde dans
l'atlantique sud
les recherches aériennes viennent d'être
déclenchée à partir de l'afrique du sud
en basketball dans le championnat de
france orthez a battu monaco 109 à 80,18
cet après midi en cyclisme c'est le jean
luc vandenbroucke qui a gagné pour la
deuxième année consécutive les toiles
désespoir une classique du sud ouest
enfin les rapports football télévision
pierre salviac vous nous résumer ce qui
a été dit dans l'émission de jean pierre
elkabbach 12h30 oui une heure de
discussion effectivement pour expliquer
aux téléspectateurs la difficulté des
rapports football télévision alors à
cette occasion chaque position a été
clairement expliquer et surtout
justifier
je rappelle les grandes lignes pour
antenne 2 d'accord pour télévisé un
grand match en direct plusieurs grands
matchs en direct même pour répondre aux
voeux des téléspectateurs pour la
fédération française de football oui à
la télévision mais pas trop souvent pour
préserver l'intérêt des clubs qui ont
besoin du public vous le savez alors à
ce stade de la discussion il fallait
bien trouver un compromis cela quand n2
précisément à créer l'événement en
donnant un monsieur dijoux le secrétaire
d'état aux sports l'occasion de proposer
ses bons offices et je vous pose
précisément d'écouter cette intervention
au moment où la discussion de moments
bien précis à l'intérieur d'une année
sportive est relativement aux fonds
exceptionnels
il serait peut-être concevable que de
mettre en place une commission
consultative
entre les organismes du football entre
la fédération française de football de
l'autre côté l'union européenne du
football et d'autre part les grandes
chaînes de télévision de façon à ce que
autour d'une table on puisse essayer de
préciser à la fois le calendrier sportif
et l'horaire des matchs et tenter de
déterminer quels sont ceux de ses
matches qu'on va retransmettre
directement voilà alors je dois ajouter
que les invités de l'émission tu accepté
la proposition de monsieur d'y jouer
qu'un calendrier va être mise au point
pour la première réunion entre la
fédération française de football l'union
européenne et de l'autre côté les
grandes chaînes de télévision un match
normalement mercredi prochain la cc le
gros problème en attendant cette
discussion il faut régler le problème du
match télévisé entre l'équipe de nantes
les l'atlético de madrid vous savez que
antennes des candidates à la télévision
de ce match mais pour l'instant il ya le
veto du football club de nantes
eh bien je propose et je m'adresse à
tous les téléspectateurs nantais les
supporteurs de nantes et ceux de la
région
si vous voulez que l'autre partie de la
france puisse voir ce match est télévisé
eh bien il vous suffit d'assister
nombreux au match qui aura lieu au stade
marcel saupin de remplir le stade
et si vous remplissez le stade en
faisant marcher au mieux l'allocation je
crois vous à vous dire dès ce soir que
le problème sera réglé et quand elle ne
sera en mesure de télévisé ce fameux
match que le reste de la france attend
avec beaucoup d'impatience
espérons que cet appel sera entendu
comme patrick poivre d'arvor vous
l'avais promis hier voici donc
maintenant la rubrique littéraire de
fans semaine du journal d'antenne de
michel tournier de l'académie goncourt
nous présente ce soir de livres mari en
quelques mots d'antoine audouard le fils
d'yves ans et puis les sirènes
d'emmanuel roblès de romans d'amour
deux histoires de couple les sirènes
ce sont les sirènes des bateaux cela se
passe dans un port anglais
en hiver le narrateur et mécaniciens et
à réparer un bateau qui est immobilisé à
quai pendant un certain temps
c'est un homme blessé il a perdu sa
femme récemment et le fait qu'il ait
perdu sa femme lui donne sur le monde en
général et sur les autres couples en
particulier à un regard approfondi un
regard plus humain un regard qui va au
fond des choses et il regarde ces
couples
notamment le couple formé par le gardien
du bateau avec son ami un homme modeste
et le couple formé par le le grand
bourgeois qui est le directeur de la
compagnie qui arme le bateau et ils
observent ces couples avec en
arrière-plan sa propre femme qui forment
en quelque sorte avec lui un troisième
couple mari en quelques mots d'antoine
audouard c'est un premier roman
antoine audouard à 20 ans c'est aussi un
roman d'amour
le roman du couple c'est un roman
d'étudiants qui se passe sur fond d'une
université de nanterre sur fond de
manifestations et aussi sur fond de
ville d'arles
ce qui n'est pas pour me déplaire il y a
trois protagonistes pierre thomas et
marie et tout se passe en dialogues très
longs en longues discussions qui durent
quelques fois toute la nuit
ce qui me frappe dans ce roman c'est la
présence extrêmement fantomatique de la
génération supérieur la génération des
pères des professeurs et disons le
des flics on a l'impression que ces
étudiants vivent dans un milieu fermé et
qui ne laisse de place qu'à leur propre
génération
c'est un problème évidemment intéressant
pour notre époque veste un problème qui
doit se poser deux fois pour antoine
audouard car antoine audouard et le fils
d'yves ans au douar écrivain célèbre
journaliste puissant et on va
certainement dire antoine audouard vous
savez et c'est le fils d'yves ans eh
bien je souhaite qu'il réussisse et
qu'il réussisse au point que dans
quelques années quand on parlera divan
audouard on dise house avait yvan
audouard c'est le père d'antoine de mode
la météo pour demain les brumes ou
brouillards seront encore nombreux le
matin mais la journée sera généralement
ensoleillé
les brouillards pourront persister
localement dans le nord-est tandis que
des passages nuageux se produiront le
soir près de l'atlantique et les
pyrénées des températures fraîches le
matin seront agréables dans l'après midi
du soleil donc et de la chaleur
pour terminer ce journal je vous propose
de réécouter la chanson sans doute la
plus célèbre de bing crosby le crooner
américain décédé hier d'une crise
cardiaque à l'âge de 73 ans les obsèques
auront lieu mardi prochain à los angeles
il a vendu plus de 200 millions de
disques ce white christmas ce noël blanc
est connu dans le monde entier
je vous retrouve en fin de soirée pour
la dernière édition et je vous laisse
donc avec celui que les américains
appelait familièrement bingo
une leçon
non
audet
marine blanc
e
oh
ce
j'ai pas
à
bonsoir
les deux terroristes japonais qui
détenait depuis ce matin dans un autobus
à nagasaki 12 personnes les deux
terroristes viennent d'être arrêtés par
la police au cours de la fusillade qui a
suivi l'un des terroristes a été tuée
tous les passagers ont été libérés ils
sont sains et saufs
apparemment donc il n'y avait aucun lien
entre cet épisode entre cette affaire de
nagasaki et de détournement du boeing de
la lufthansa qui est toujours immobilisé
ce soir sur les pistes de l'aéroport de
dubaï
sous la menace des armes du commando qui
s'est emparé de l'avion les 82 passagers
les cinq membres de l'équipage vont
passer donc leur troisième nuit à bord
du boeing
pourront-ils dormir bien difficile de
répondre la fatigue l'angoissé doivent
se mêler avec à chaque fois une question
qui doit revenir
que va faire le gouvernement allemand
personne ne le sait pour l'instant
aucune information n'ayant filtré des
diverses réunions qui se sont tenues
aujourd'hui à bonn une chose est sûre
quand même les membres du commando sont
nerveux la preuve ce soir ils n'ont pas
hésité à tirer sur les voitures de
l'armée de dubaï qui s'était approché un
peu trop près à leur goût du boeing cet
ami dit gmt demain il sera 13 heures à
paris qui expirera l'ultimatum fixé par
les auteurs du détournement de l'avion
de la lufthansa immobilisé ici sur
l'aéroport de dubaï c'est d'ici là les
11 membres de la bande à baader détenu
en allemagne et deux palestiniens
prisonniers en turquie ne sont pas
libérés les terroristes menacent de
faire sauter l'avion avec les 80 deux
otages l'ultimatum ne sera pas retardé
pas même d'une seconde
on précisait les terroristes qui ont
refusé une nouvelle fois de libérer les
femmes et les enfants qu'ils détiennent
dans un appel pathétique
le commandant de bord de l'avion a
demandé au gouvernement allemand de tout
faire pour sauver la vie des passagers
une angoisse qui est aussi partagée par
l'opinion allemande qui attend les
décisions que devront prendre ses
dirigeants et à la chancellerie de
bonnes l'état major de crise présidée
par le chancelier helmut schmidt a siégé
pratiquement sans désemparer toute la
journée et le contact a été maintenue
sans motive
d'une part avec le commando de dubaï et
d'autre part avec les ravisseurs de
monsieur ins martin schleyer le patron
des patrons
mais ce matin une fuite a fait échouer
la remise d'une rançon de 15 millions de
dollars qui devaient être effectués par
le fils de monsieur flyers dans un hôtel
de francfort pour le chancelier helmut
schmidt
le choix est difficile on peut penser
néanmoins qu'il a choisi de sauver avant
tout la vie des otages
car ce soir la télévision allemande a
diffusé un message de monsieur flyers
qui avaient été transmis par ses
ravisseurs tout maintenant va se jouer
dans les heures qui viennent et la tante
sera longue
l'ultimatum donc expire à 13 heures
heure française demain la nuit dernière
en france la police a effectué des
contrôles importance sur le canal de la
marne à la saône but de ces
investigations retrouver un bateau
transportant le patron des patrons
restent allemand monsieur schleier et
ses ravisseurs pour l'instant les
policiers n'ont rien trouvé
monsieur raymond barre au micro d'europe
1 ce soir à exprimer personnellement
toute sa sympathie à l'allemagne
fédérale et a déclaré que le
gouvernement français était must de ce
qui se passe à dubaï
le premier ministre a inauguré cet
après-midi et l'opération portes
ouvertes organisée par le cnpf avant ces
assises nationales de lundi et de mardi
prochain
monsieur bart s'est déclaré
reconnaissant vis-à-vis des chefs
d'entreprise pour l'effort qu'ils font
face aux difficultés de la conjoncture
le travail ne doit pas être une activité
servile mais doit servir à
l'accomplissement de l'être humain a
également déclaré le premier ministre
de son côté monsieur françois ceyrac
devant près de 4000 cadres a souhaité
une extension du rôle de l'encadrement
dans l'entreprise et a proposé d usine à
la campagne porte close en revanche pour
le conseil national du parti républicain
des travaux à huis clos aujourd'hui et
demain pour mettre au point le projet
républicain
le programme électoral du parti de jean
pierre soisson les portes se sont quand
même entre ouverte pendant quelques
instants
durant notre journal de 20h ce soir le
secrétaire général du parti républicain
nous a expliqué en effet que le p r
soutiendra les objectifs d'action de
monsieur raymond barre pour les
socialistes ce samedi 15 novembre était
une journée nationale de formation le
début d'une grande campagne
d'explication un usage des militants sur
le thème de l'identité du parti le parti
socialiste n'a qu'un combat celui qu'il
mène contre la droite
il n'a qu'une stratégie l'union de la
gauche a répété ce soir monsieur pierre
bérégovoy au cours d'une réunion à metz
pour sa part jacques chirac qui parlait
à tulle a violemment attaqué françois
mitterrand disant qu'il s'était
constamment trompé depuis 30 un nouvel
accident sur une plateforme de forage
dans la mer du nord
la nuit dernière nouveau problème de
soupape cette fois il y à un mort un
plongeur français qui a été tué alors
qu'il essayait de réparer une soupape
défectueuse le gaz naturel continue de
s'échapper ce soir tous les techniciens
évacuer la plate forme à cause du danger
d'explosion une dizaine de bateaux de
pêche se maintiennent autour de la fuite
de gaz pour écarter d'éventuels navires
normalement il ne doit pas y avoir de
pollution car le gaz naturel doit
disparaître rapidement à la surface de
la mer
janus quatre opérations commencées
depuis ce matin six plongeurs ont entamé
la compression but de l'expérience
prouvé que l'homme peut travailler sous
la mer jusqu'à 500 mètres de profondeur
l'opération doit durer huit jours si
elle réussit ce sera une grande première
mondiale le contrat nucléaire franco
iranien pour la livraison de deux
centrales devrait être signé dimanche à
téhéran monsieur robert boulin le
ministre délégué aux finances qui doit
signer pour la france est arrivé ce soir
dans la capitale iranienne
le contrat porte sur près de 15
milliards de francs
le corps du soldat inconnu tombé en
afrique du nord etc
sera inhumé demain dimanche au cimetière
national de lorette dans le pas de
calais en présence du président de la
république ce corps est arrivé cet après
midi à arras le chef de l'état ranimera
la flamme de lorette après avec le
flambeau de l'arc de triomphe et
prononcera une allocution avant le dépôt
du cercueil dans une crypte les obsèques
du chanteur américain bing crosby décédé
hier d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge de 73
ans seront célébrées mardi à los angeles
je suis sûr que c'est la mort que mon
père avait souhaité juste après une
bonne partie de golf a expliqué son fils
aujourd'hui pour dire que le célèbre
crooner était depuis des années déjà un
véritable passionné du golf en france
plus de 200 mille personnes meurent
chaque année de maladies
cardiovasculaires
pour mieux sensibiliser tous les
français à ces problèmes du
fonctionnement de notre coeur une
exposition va être organisée elle est
même organisé déjà et va même duré
plusieurs mois au palais de la
découverte
on y apprend ce que c'est qu'un choeur
normale et comment éviter de devenir
malade à votre bon coeur partie de la
réunion chacun d'entre nous va pouvoir
personnellement écouter battre son coeur
ou encore enregistrer lui-même son
électrocardiogramme
c'est l'un des moyens de sensibilisation
retenu pour nous apprendre le plus
aimablement du monde à connaître notre
coeur et surtout à le ménager des la
jeunesse à l'aide de maquettes animées
de panneaux électroniques de films de
tableaux éducatif les cardiologues ont
décidé de faire prendre conscience au
plus large public que la pompe cardiaque
est fait pour battre en moyenne 70 fois
par minute pendant 100 ans mais à
condition qu'on ne lui fasse pas mener
une vie impossible
ce qu'il faut maintenant c'est prévenir
et l'on peut se fixer l'objectif alors
2000 réduire de 30 % des maladies du
coeur et l'infarctus du myocarde est ce
si j'allais dire à bas prix par des
mesures simples diminué nettement la
consommation des cigarettes diminue et
l'alimentation
corrigés pour les seuls faits pour
lesquels ces perturber le cholestérol le
sucre dans le sang
voilà un ensemble de mesures dans toutes
les études épidémiologiques permettent
d'affirmer qu'ils seront efficaces
une exposition remarquable fait pour que
chacun comprenne qu'il est préférable de
s'informer de prévenir les menaces
plutôt que de réparer à grands frais et
tant bien que mal des lésions ou d
accident qui aurait pu être évitée les
films sont diffusés pendant cette
exposition il faut aussi savoir qu'après
le palais des découvertes cette
exposition se promènera un peu partout
en france
enfin aujourd'hui d'une manifestation
qui n'a pas fait l'unanimité loin de là
le premier festival de la femme au
palais des congrès alice sapritch et
marthe richard ont participé au débat de
clôture cet après midi sur le thème la
femme est l'amour un sujet tout trouvé
évidemment pour les reporters de la
lorgnette de jacques martin et stéphane
colas en sport le voilier 33 export a
disparu dans l'atlantique sud à la fin
de la première étape de la course autour
du monde
les avions sud-africains sont partis à
la recherche du yacht français
normalement il aurait dû être au cap
depuis plusieurs jours en football
demain dimanche au parc des princes pour
la première fois en france l'équipe
d'israël jouera contre une sélection
française une équipe française plutôt il
s'agira du paris saint-germain match à
16h au parc dépasse et puis je pense que
nous avons peut-être les résultats de la
division 2 maintenant qui vient de nous
parvenir
voilà d'ailleurs le cas du groupe à en
deuxième division trois matchs ont lieu
dimanche cannes chaumont par le
martigues et ajaccio fontainebleau a
remarqué le match nul entre béziers et
alès et le bon résultat à l'extérieur de
toulouse qui a gagné 1 à 0 devant melun
dans le groupe b voici les résultats
victoire à l'extérieur de bresse devant
caen 2 1 lille a gagné 4 1 à tours
gueugnon a perdu à guingamp 1 à 0 le red
star a également perdu à angoulême 1 à 0
y'avait aussi je pense des résultats
voici le classement de la deuxième
division avant de passer au basketball
francs est toujours lille tours et
châteauroux vote star quatrième lucet
cinquième est tout à fait en bas de
classement nous retrouvons guingamp à la
17e place
et quant à la 18e place
je pense qu'il y avait aussi des
résultats de basket-ball je pense que
nous les avons reçus tu attends juste un
instant pour confirmer non nous avons
pas reçu donc nous passons maintenant
pour terminer ce journal est une
histoire de vache une vache et de
tableau frédéric que brandon un jeune
peintre qui expose actuellement à
honfleur comme beaucoup d'artistes aime
traiter un seul sujet à la fois il a
d'abord peint madrid
ensuite il a peint le rugby entre temps
et lieu les veaux et les vaches sans
lesquels la normandie ne serait pas ce
qu'elle est super u être pire en fait
des tableaux sont souvent réussi
m
lors d'une visite guidée par un ami bush
et dans les abattoirs de caen j'ai été
frappé par par cette vision j'ai eu et
par l'aboutissement des vaches qui sont
comme j'habite la normandie mon cadre
naturel donc j'ai eu l'idée de faire dix
ans le cheminement de la vache du pré de
la bétaillère est finie aux abattoirs
j'ai pas fait la boucherie par elle même
mais normalement aujourd'hui finir sur
bifteck
mais je me suis arrêté et matra
que la vache un côté attendrissant c'est
ça à mes yeux doux mais la vache
derrière barbelés déjà ce un peu moins
douces et de l'élevage de poulets film
en jeu côté sinistre
quand on regarde le barbelé et après 30
ans ou dans les abattoirs on s'aperçoit
de tout ce cheminement un petit peu
comme ça concentrationnaire enfin petit
peu peu difficile finalement je regarde
plus les âges comme j'ai rien avant
n'arrive pas en une seule toile
finalement dire ce qu'on a envie de dire
donc une toile en amène une autre sur le
même sujet et on peut difficilement
mélanger c'est les sujets mans series
des vaches
je n'ai fait que des vaches série du
rugby en ce moment je travaille je ne
fête du rugby série sur madrid j'ai pris
un bang madrid et j'ai fait vingt toiles
sur madrid c'est à dire que je ne peux
travailler que sur un sujet je pense
comme un peu un écrivain c'est à dire
que il fait il raconte une histoire ou
un roman ou un essai ça n'empêche pas de
prendre des notes sur autre chose mais
finalement il se concentre totalement
sur ce finalement on raconte une
histoire
m
un jeune pâtre jusqu'à 50 ans est obligé
de faire des boulots annexe des choses
comme ça on ne peut pas trop et en
province encore pire si ce n'est
effectivement si je faisais des ports
dont flair et que j'allais les vendent
le dimanche
là j'aurai des chances ans débarque sur
l'eau des choses comme ça où démarrait
de sallenelles peut-être d'en vendre
quelques-uns mais si on veut faire une
peinture plus universel un pâtre à 35
ans commence à peine les marchands n'ont
aucune confiance dans un point pas 35
ans il est trop loin de la main voilà
entre temps j'ai réussi à obtenir les
résultats du basket donc je vous
rappelle le match qui a lieu mercredi
dernier à antibes antibes avait battu
caen 104 à 91
je veux rappeler maintenant les équipes
qui ont gagné ce soir en championnat
orthez villeurbanne le mans tours
bagnolet berck et miss au classement
donc de ce championnat de france de
basket en tête le mans orthez berck
villeurbanne avec 6 points 5e position
tour avignon clermont caen monaco anti
bagnolet et nice de mode à météo avant
de se quitter pour ce soir il y aura de
la brume demain matin et des brouillards
dans beaucoup de régions en particulier
dans le nord-est de la france et sur
l'alsace et la lorraine du soleil dans
l'après-midi un peu partout quelques
nuages et des risques d'orage dans le
sud ouest et dans le golfe du lion je
vous retrouverai demain avec plaisir à
13 heures pour une édition complète du
journal d'antenne 2 d'ici là je vous
souhaite une très belle nuit